hey youtubers is Charlie its ok this
week on The Walking Dead
directly picked up after that Big Bob
WTF moment in
look pretty much like it was written
rate of the comic book page if you
haven't read the comics
the last two episodes were pretty much
right at a volume 11 fear the hunters
you should be able to buy that on
comiXology at a big discount if you want
to go back and see how it all went down
there were a few minor changes that I'll
explain also you enter the giveaway
start
right now so are you to dinner is
business member leave a comment on this
video
so careful if you're not cut up on
Walking Dead starting with
top five moments number five tainted
meat
so this was the conclusion to become a
big scene from last week bob
waking up realizing the hundreds that
eaten his leg in the comic it was Dale
but everything else on the show pretty
much went down like it did in the comics
he starts laughing hysterically in says
you idiots I've been bitten
the %ah spit out the barbecue and up a
model on to Step freak everyone at the
church out
they did say that they're gonna be doing
a lot more compliments this year so be
on the lookout for other big like WTF
things if you have been reading the
comics
number forty Briel explains backstory
also went down pretty much the way went
on the comics
he showed his congregation out when the
apocalypse hit it was too scared to let
them in whenever the walkers came
he had to listen to them all be ripped
apart even the little children so he
will know it's
these were getting pretty crazy inside
the group I mean obviously Gabriel was
the source in the tension previously but
now you have Sasha
neighbor him generally they kinda cool
down though it seem like everyone pretty
much called off
internet gaming again down gabriel's
throat anymore not that he's like their
best friend yet
I did like his reaction to what they did
two hundred later in the episode
is a church I Beach the dizzy been with
the group starts to socialize him a
little bit more research to regain
smoothies humanity
I don't think I'll ever find redemption
I mean it just doesn't seem like it's
part of his character that you can
forgive himself
but it is possible he could martyr
himself in some biblical way at the
opportunity ever presented itself
again City the company cuter it's
possible to take ages
played a character at the way he is in
the comics number three
Abraham verses Rick it started to tease
intention with Abraham in the last
episode
with him wanting to take up for DC in a
group not wanting to split up
they did reach a compromise but the
interesting thing is that but they took
off in
in the trailer is seem like flipping
through the air so clearly something
crazy
to be happening into next week looks
like a better person
we might have to wait two weeks to find
out what's going on with that group
just like last year though it seems like
they're splitting storylines of
in just give us an opportunity to see
more places here's a good look at the
map that Abraham gave them
that city the route to Washington DC
because the whole reason for them
splitting up was waiting for Darrell in
Carroll
intel's back now I think we're going to
find out where they're going next
I'm easy as pie can have something to do
with Caroline bed we didn't see who's
behind the road into the absurd
but I'm guessing that it was not Carol
otherwise she would just come right out
like they would be made its way to find
out number two
hunting the hunters this was also
continuation that fear the hunter
storyline from the comics
reckon the survivors trap the hunters
using the church
they turned themselves in debate so
Chris the leader the hunters walks and
obviously on the show it's Garrett so
the comic story goes in a slightly
different direction
essentially in the same way though in
the comics it was the next morning
really do with Chris on the show
obviously rate keeps his promise and
slices the hell out of them
definitely one of the best crazy Rick
moments that when he gets crazy scary
you can kinda tell the rest of the group
is looking at him a little bit
differently after this
even though he tries to justify it you
saw what they were capable up
essentially he's becoming darker and
darker I think judy is obviously is
counterbalance in
they had that nice mom with pop at the
end so it does seem like rick is hopeful
into the message on the map to the new
worlds gonna need Rick Grimes
so I think there was a hopeful spin on
his character they've always been like
comparisons between Rick and the
governor
like to very similar people the
governors to get little too far
& Butter Berlin WTF moment bob is dead
he was a marked man the minute he got
bit and didn't tell anyone
they might have been able to save him if
they treated him right away
there's really no official time line is
to how long it takes for someone who's
been to turn
but if it's been more than 12 hours you
pretty much guarantee dead
and a lot of people were curious about
the teen in me if the hunters would
return
if they eat the meat technically no I
mean he would have to be in
a decade person but you have to eat one
of those waterlogged walkers
in return him dying was a comic book
scene but obviously had to change a lot
of things because they don't have
in re anymore in the comments in re is
the 1d killed Dale
deal obviously being the bad character
in that version she shoot them in the
head after they declare their love for
each other and he dies
on the show such a hater night but
Terry's took it Eagle Bob
for her I think just as her big brother
he was just trying to preserve some of
her innocence like
he didn't want her to go to that place
but she still relatively innocent person
not quite as it is in his bed although
that might change for her soon
but she hasn't gone that crazy place but
I reasons been to that he's trying to
stay away from
like not killing people if the Taliban a
moment
Imbert only gonna miss Bob but I think
they give his character really good
send-up
everyone got to say their goodbyes even
some of them had their own scenes with
Mike reconcile show
most characters don't get that but I do
really like when walking two kills one
of the main characters of
they do it in a really memorable way
either really attic
or really poignant like with Bob they
will take area they may carry out but
they will take area
energy West the guy that plays Gareth
action revealed its got people many
called in to come on season 5 he said
full disclosure we're going to clean up
a soda 3
anything it's funny that from behind the
scenes standpoint you know actors
typically no what's going on if you're
gonna be dying really soon
full disclosure you know you can say no
if you want we're gonna kill you at this
moment
I don't think that anyone would say no
to coming on walking dead even if they
knew they were gonna die really soon
there was little bit confusion because
people have been reporting
energy West had been up to series
regular in series regulars usually
appear in most if not all the episodes
so
them I just been inaccurate you wait
next week early bath episode brothers
the gonna find out who's with the role
to
he'll prolly explain what went on with
him in care on their side trip
if anyone had a chance to play it
there's actually a video game that might
reveal little bit about what's going on
with the No a character is was bad
it's called The Walking Dead survival
instinct it said in the world in the TV
universe like it's not like that Walking
Dead Telltale game
it may not necessarily be what happens
on the show but in the game deal goes to
Cleburne Memorial Hospital
me know bet on the show's going to be at
a hospital but the game description:
just in the wiki reads you know when the
outbreak began government research crew
took
residents actually burn Memorial
Hospital they had military protection
the captain operational
deal arrives looking for a robotics from
rural finds Noah
who was treated for gunshot wound leader
finds doctor searching for a cure
experimenting on Noah as a test subject
India has to choose whether or not save
Noah
so Beth could be like that no a
character in the game
but that still leaves the question about
what's going on with Carol and we
haven't seen the new a character on the
show yet to tell James Williams
character
so lot to be questions hopefully most
those will get answer next week
but it's basically going to be just like
the governor episode during season 4
will be all about bet that like rewind
in time
to the time when she was taken there
have been leaked images from the best
episode so if you watch that clip or use
others images
just please use per taxi going to
comment on them below because most
people probably haven't seen em
let me know that what was your favorite
moment in the episode and what do you
think happened to Daryl
care when they went to find bet overall
you the episode is all B-plus
it was a solid annotation up a comic
book moment are several companies
moments
to give nice end of the book geared and
Bob I really like the way they did the
ending
obviously Garrett had a diner Levi away
you live by the sword you die by the
sword
the Bach your turn general just had a
really great are gonna show
I mean he was essentially been a douche
bag during season 4 recovering alcoholic
we just kept getting into trouble
because it is addiction in the second
half to the season he turned his life
around
in fell in love with Sasha obviously
that didn't work out
even though he kinda got himself in
trouble in this episode again but he got
himself captured
he is at his core a good person you'll
be missed bob
we will miss you especially Sasha is pry
can get really dark now
there's no way she's gonna let go that
anger terraces like the voice of reason
in the episode
I was a little disappointed and Sasha
when she demanded
Tyreese stay with them rather than she
do it there's a lot of people have
proper sizing that she might turn into
comic book
Andrea you can let me know whether not
you agree with that but I do think that
sasha is gonna toughen up a little bit
but she's gonna go slightly in a key
role direction you can't replace carroll
et you not gonna be Carol
but she will just get a little bit
harder that's also the big teaser for
bed to
this is gonna be like the season where
she toughens up Evolver die
overall I just I really love the
direction shows gone this season
it has been a nice twist I mean I really
to the second half a season for
I see the first half season 4 not quite
as exciting but you know we did at the
mid-season WTF
there been so many other rumors about
which characters might die this season
though
I think it's a little early to speculate
but I do think that somebody else is
gonna die during the mid-season finale
so I will be posting a video for this
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
it
leave all your questions and if you have
read the comics just
remember to use per tax if you've read
ahead what other big stuff going on to
marble has like a big announcement going
on Tuesdays are trying it someone's body
is up for that too
right now you can actually click here to
get back to anybody I the annotations is
a person tomorrow
and you can click here my episode 2
bar-bq video
thank you so much for watching Fort all
hype I and say one more goodbye to bob